Mandalorian's great.
Yes, it is.
Mandalorian's awesome.
No, if they, if they did the whole series
the way this thing looks like
a spaghetti Western in space,
I would have been all over it.
Well, it's so funny, by the way,
Because I liked, you
know, I like Blade Runner.
Here's what's amazing, what you just said.
So I was 12, my aunt and uncle were
what they used to call rotoscope artists.
Rotoscoping was the original
special effects by hand.
They would have to paint,
hand paint individual frames
of movies to do things,
and they told me, I said,
"What are you working on?"
Because I wanted to be in the movies.
I was 12 years old
and they go, "We're doing
this like really dumb movie."
"It's basically like a
spaghetti Western in space."
"It's called 'Star Wars,
and we're drawing in the laser beams."
So literally the people who first worked
on the original "Star Wars" thought
it was a spaghetti Western in space.
Wow.
And that's what you're,
what you're picking up on,
on Mandalorian.
Clearly Favreau, you know, knew that,
and that's why he's so great,
as a director, Jon Favreau.
Yeah, and they're like such
huge, ridiculous fans of it.
So I think it works for me
not knowing a lot about it.
So then the weight of it,
which I didn't understand
until the first season came out
and then like this whole new
group of people were coming up
to me, super polite, "Star Wars" fans.
At least when they meet you.
I don't know how they are on the internet.
I haven't read anything, but
like, they come up very polite
and like ridiculously passionate about,
it's like sports passion for a show, so.
For sure.
I've gotten, it's been real
cool that they came, you know,
it's funny, I get shit, though.
They go, "I never heard a Boston accent
in a galaxy far, far away."
And I always go like,
"Well, how about English?"
"You don't think it's weird
that they're all speaking English?"
(laughs)
What was, what was the question?
The whole thing's ridiculous.
Exactly.
There's a Sasquatch.
(attempts Wookiee roar) Yeah.
Yeah.
The Wookiee.
And what I love is Han Solo
still speaks in English to him
and they both understand each other
but he doesn't grunt like him
and he doesn't speak in
English to him, but it works.
You can't, you can't start
using that kind of logic
in "Star Wars"
or the whole thing falls
apart pretty quickly.
Exactly. Then they should
leave my Boston accent alone.
(laughs)